le pedí a mi pareja que considerara
aportar
321 vamos
jubilee presenta spectrum invitamos a 6
padres adolescentes para comprobar el
alcance de sus creencias y valores
me emocioné al enterarme de que sería
papá
321 vamos
ser papá fue una mezcla de emociones y
si estaba asustado te cambia la vida
para siempre es decir todo en tu vida
cambia por completo y de repente ya lo
tenía planeado quería un bebé cuando era
pequeño siempre cuidaba de mis hermanos
mis padres trabajaban mucho mi mamá
trabajaba mucho por supuesto mis padres
no estaban juntos sí creo que he estado
listo desde pequeño siempre quise tener
un bebé en la adolescencia no sé por qué
yo sólo sabía que quería ser papá yo
estaba muy emocionado porque mi novia ya
tenía un bebé así que queríamos que
quedara embarazada y cuando vi el
positivo en la prueba de embarazo me
emocioné mucho pero es obvio que también
estaba nervioso nos enteramos de que
seríamos padres tres días antes de que
me fuera a la universidad así que no lo
tome muy bien porque me preocupaba qué
iba a pasar con mi estadía en la
universidad y con los planes que
teníamos para el futuro porque nada
parecía encajar pensábamos que las cosas
serían de cierta forma pero todo cambió
repentinamente mi familia acepta que
tenga un bebé a mi edad
21 vamos
mi familia estaba muy emocionada y
fueron las primeras personas que se
enteraron porque la verdad es que
teníamos miedo de decirles a otras
personas en ese entonces mi mamá tuvo mi
hermano mayor cuando era muy joven y no
los m a mí siempre me han gustado mucho
los niños si al igual que a ustedes
chicos mi mamá de mi papá me tuvieron
muy jóvenes pero creo que para mí fue
muy difícil decirles porque se
esforzaron mucho para que yo no hiciera
lo mismo que ellos hicieron mi mamá tuvo
varios empleos para mantenernos a mi
hermana ya mí y fue muy difícil decirles
porque no quería que sintiera que había
fallado hizo mucho por mí y me dio una
buena educación y la oportunidad de ir a
la universidad pero al final cometí el
mismo error así que me costó mucho
decirle cuando le hablé a mi papá sobre
el embarazo de laura
estábamos peleados él me había echado de
casa y no habíamos hablado durante unos
meses
así que le escribí y le dije sabes serás
el abuelo que nunca apoyo
creo creo que solo hizo reaccionar así
que decidió que iba a apoyarme mi mamá y
yo pensamos casi igual usualmente así
que ella sabía que pasaría la invité a
desayunar en mi cumpleaños y cuando le
enseñamos la prueba solo dijo ya lo
sabía mi mamá y yo hemos tenido una
buena relación desde que era pequeño
bueno cuando estaba en la escuela y
vivía con ella aún cuando se enteró del
embarazo pensé que se alegraría pero eso
cambió cuando vi su reacción yo esa
mañana solo
dijo no si tienes un bebé te vas de aquí
y harás todo por tu cuenta encontrarás
tu propio camino ahora me siento algo
mal pero mi bebé no tiene relación
alguna con mi mamá mi familia no me
apoyo tanto como lo esperaba al
principio pero a medida que pasaba el
tiempo y cuando llegaron los bebés
comenzaron a aceptar las cosas es solo
que mis padres tenían grandes planes
para mí querían que fuera cuatro años a
la universidad obtuviera mi título y
siguiera adelante
supongo que vieron esto como algo que
arruinaría esos planes se cambiaría todo
recibí educación sobre los métodos
anticonceptivos antes de tener
relaciones
321 vamos
[Música]
al hablar sobre métodos anticonceptivos
pienso más en las mujeres porque para
los hombres sólo existe el condones todo
no sabía de eso no sabía cómo usar uno
tuve que aprender por mi cuenta puedo
decir que aprendí todo cuando comencé a
salir con mi esposa después de que
tuvimos al bebé entonces fue cuando
aprendí más sobre los métodos y todo eso
sin duda mi esposo y yo sabíamos sobre
los métodos me parece que no nos
preocupaba si había un embarazo así que
no usamos ninguno es decir si si
conocíamos los preservativos ella tomaba
la píldora pero paro durante un tiempo y
entonces ya saben solo pasó la única
clase que tomé fue en la secundaria solo
solo una clase y no duró ni siquiera un
mes fue sólo una semana le pedí a mi
pareja que considerara abortar
321 vamos
si sabias en lo que te metías al tener
relaciones o sabias las consecuencias
que eso podría tener no deberías
considerar el aborto al menos no como
una posible opción si sabes que estás
haciendo y conoces los riesgos que
podría haber debes aceptarlo en lo
personal no tengo problemas con el
aborto pero en mi caso sería es algo una
decisión con la que no habría podido
vivir no sé opinó que la vida es algo
valioso
hay que considerar todas las opciones es
decir si voy a traer a un niño el mundo
no querré que no que viva mal desde el
principio no querría que creciera en un
lugar en el que ni siquiera podrán
alimentarlo le dije a mi novia si vamos
a tenerlo tenemos que comprometernos
tenemos que darle todo el bebé pasa a
ser la prioridad se cambia es tu
mentalidad y trabajas duro y tomas las
decisiones correctas puedes lograr
cualquier cosas y puede que sea difícil
como dijiste pero puedes hacer que no lo
sea en el momento en que nos enteramos
estaba por irme a la universidad iba a
mudarme de casa y mi novia tenía planes
de ir a la universidad
ciudad salir del estado viajar y todas
estas cosas así que hablamos sobre el
aborto la adopción y otras opciones que
podríamos considerar porque no se
estresaba mucho no saber cómo
conseguiríamos el dinero ya que ninguno
de los dos tenía educación universitaria
o algo así tengo una buena relación con
la mamá de mi bebé
321 vamos
diré que tengo una buena relación con la
mamá de mi bebé es decir estamos casados
aún tenemos algunos problemas porque
debimos mudarnos al otro extremo del
país lejos de su familia pero creo que
ahora mismo antes de conseguir empleos o
algo así es el mejor momento de
fortalecernos y creo que es justo lo que
hacemos decidí mudarme con la madre de
mis bebés y fue muy estresante porque
por supuesto pasamos de no tener ningún
bebé a tener dos al mismo tiempo después
de un tiempo terminamos pero ahora
trabajamos en nuestra relación nos
turnamos de modo que cada uno pueda
cuidarlos yo me encargo de ellos cuando
ella va a estudiar y cada uno tiene
tiempo para hacer lo que quiera en lugar
de estar rodeados de bebés las 24 horas
considere no formar parte de la vida de
mi bebé
321 vamos
creo que eso es lo peor que se puede
hacer en primer lugar embarazar a
alguien y quizás no sea arruinar su
futuro se planeaban ir a la universidad
ya sabes algo más no solo arruinaría su
vida sino también la del bebé que
procrea este es por eso que creo que es
lo peor si apenas me enteré de que mi
novia estaba embarazada
dejé el fútbol de inmediato quería pasar
todo todo mi tiempo disponible con ella
porque no quería que hiciera esto sola
como él dijo sí pero creaste una vida
entonces debes formar parte de la vida
de ese bebé y acompañarlo en su
desarrollo incluso si no estás con su
mamá creo que la figura paterna es muy
muy importante en la vida de un niño si
saben hay muchos padres que entran a la
vida de los niños saben pero los niños
no desean verlos porque solo piensan en
que nunca estuvieron presentes y yo yo
no quiero sentir ese dolor eso debe
doler mucho querer estar con una
criatura con la que no estuviste desde
el principio y no sólo eso porque
e incluso si quieren verte no sabes que
les gusta van a comer pizza o pasta o
algo más si te dice que no le gusta eso
debe doler sabía que yo tenía que formar
parte de la vida de mis hijos y que
ellos tenían que ser parte de la mía
pero fue muy difícil al principio porque
no tenía buenas influencias o personas
que me dijeran que estaba bien la
mayoría de mis allegados decían que era
una mala idea que estaba mal excepto por
la [ __ ] de los bebés fue de verdad muy
difícil pero sabía que debía estar con
ellos puedo mantener a mi bebé
monetariamente 321 vamos
en lo personal agradezco la oportunidad
que nos dan los canales de youtube
porque podemos ganar dinero y con eso
incluso podemos abrir cuentas de ahorros
para nuestros hijos en mi caso quiero
estudiar abogacía y eso toma algunos
años no podría apoyar económicamente
durante algún tiempo así que sin la
ayuda de mi familia y familia de mi
novia no podría no podría hacer nada de
esto si en mi caso trabajaba en una a un
trabajo en una iglesia pero solo un día
a la semana siempre pensé que no era
suficiente así que ahora tengo dos
trabajos de medio tiempo pero admito que
al principio fue difícil se sentía
horrible y no quería que mi mamá tuviera
que pagar por los pañales o las
toallitas cuando le pides dinero a otras
personas ahora intentó conseguir dinero
como pueda sí criar a un niño ya es un
trabajo con realidad y más y hay que
estudiar al mismo tiempo trabajar
estudiar criar un bebé el servicio
militar youtube todo eso de verdad te
consume si quieres pasar todo tu tiempo
con tus hijos pero no fue le es muy
difícil estar lejos
y de alguna manera hay que sacrificarse
para tener una estabilidad económica ya
sabes o hacer las cosas que quieres y
parte de esos sacrificios es no pasar
tiempo con tu familia si el viernes me
invitaron a una fiesta universitaria
para estudiantes y cosas así no fuiste
el querer divertirte es una tentación
saben pero en lugar de asistir fui a
cenar con mi familia y eso es ahora que
lo pienso es mucho mejor
si siento que me juzgan por ser un papá
adolescente 321 vamos
no me concentro en la negatividad soy
muy optimista pero mis compañeros de
fútbol me juzgan saben y dicen cosas
inadecuadas sobre mi novia y dicen que
es una cualquiera o cosas por el estilo
pero me di cuenta de que nunca fueron
mis amigos así que cuando se burlan de
mí no dejo que me afecte sé que importa
en realidad y eso es
[Música]
no estará ahí para mi familia desde que
era niño me decían debes ir a la
universidad debes estudiar mucho tienes
que graduarte debes conseguir un empleo
etcétera etcétera y eso apesta porque
solo quieres probar que puedes hacer lo
que podrás graduarte y sé que puedo
hacerlo de todas formas aunque algunos
miembros de mi familia me juzgan también
algunos amigos cuando estoy en clases y
conozco gente nueva
proponen ir a estudiar yo digo no puedo
debo volver a casa y cuidar a mi bebé
solo me miran y piensan que como tengo
un hijo renunciaré en cualquier momento
hay muchos estereotipos sobre el tema
muchas perspectivas pregunto si nos
sentíamos juzgados y creo que la palabra
que más destacó para mí fue sentir
porque no me importa lo que piensa la
gente así que lo que dice no me hace
sentir nada no no sé si vamos a la
tienda y la gente se nos queda viendo
solo voltea y les digo oye qué demonios
estás viendo y después me voy porque es
decir qué significado tienen ellos en mi
vida ninguno porque soy yo quien está
cambiando la suya
de verdad no me importa lo que piense la
gente mi momento favorito es cuando
preguntan dónde está la mamá
justo aquí estás guapo
bien cuidado creo que tenga su novio
tampoco lo creo así que bonito pero la
que está alineada mira vamos chicos
listos sonríe jubilee vive más